[Musique]
salut à tous vous êtes bien sur
envergure la chaîne qui vous parle de
vos prospects favoris de vos futurs star
NBA et des autres rle players on est sur
un nouveau podcast qui s'appelle five
star donc là on va vous parler surtout
des gens qu'on attend assez haut dans la
draft de 2024 avec un portrait qui va
être ciselé ça va pas durer très
longtemps c'est 20 minutes ça va être
très intense très physique euh on va
essayer d'aborder un peu toutes les
composantes qui font de pourquoi ce
prospect évaluable pourquoi il est
intéressant pour ce premier épisode on
va partir en direction de l'Un
université de douke en passant par
l'Australie on va parler d'un garde il
s'appelle tharis Proctor et pour se
faire ce soir ou cette journée selon de
quand vous écoutez le podcast je suis
accompagné de Manu et de HUG messieurs
comment allez-vous salut à tous on va
très bien je fa bien en tout cas mais
pareimement mais moi je suis tellement
heureux là de reprendre oh là là
l'excitation voilà c'est la reprise on
est dans les starting blocs euh HUG on
va commencer avec toi on va partir sur
l'histoire de de ce jeune homme qui
est-il d'où vient-il cet incroyable
robot et ben Tyris Proctor la première
fois qu'on m'en a parlé la première
chose que je me suis dit c'est je
connais pas ce mec euh ce méchant de
Superman et après je me suis rendu
compte que ça c'est l'ex lutor donc il a
absolument rien à voir euh mais je l'ai
capté assez vite vous savez quel indice
j'ai eu la coupe de cheveux c'est un
truc très envergueure non non mais c'est
justement qu'on est chez envergure et
qu'on parle de basket et
ouais ça joue je t'avoue ça joue ça m'a
un peu aiguillé euh le problème en fait
c'est qu'actuellement NBA comme on parle
tu vois de de Superman et den tout le
temps moi je confonds un peu hein je
suis un peu perdu et les gens aussi
sûrement et ce que je vous propose c'est
que j'ai volé un concept américain j'ai
volé le 94 fet avec J Baas pour le faire
version française donc le 94 pied avec
HUG deall ce qui est un peu moins stylé
mais c'est un hommage à ben tu vois euh
et donc je vais vous donner trois facts
sur Taris Proctor il y en a deux qui
sont fausses et une qui est vraie et
attention messieurs faut trouver
laquelle est vraie vous êtes prêts vas-y
ah ouais je vous je vous avais prévenu
hein je vous avais prévenu que que
j'avais travaillé euh la première Facte
sur Tyris Proctor c'est qui s'appelle
Tyris parce que son papa était un grand
fan de TERA liberton à sa naissance
ouis la la deuxième fact euh c'est que
c'est un menur de jeu d' 1,96 pour 79 kg
sauf au Mor euh pour les duces BL dev
ville et qui est né en Australie euh qui
est le fils d'un papa qui s'appelle raod
mais lui il a choisi de faire sa propre
voix et qui était aussi un joueur de
basket et il a hésité entre le criquet
et le basketball quand il a grandi et
puis il a vu le salaire au RSA des
joueurs de cricket donc il a choisi le
basketball
finalement et il a été élu dans le dans
les meilleurs CIN de la ACC à Duke et la
troisième fact c'est qui s'appelle tyis
Proctor et qui vient d'une longue fam de
proctologue et donc ça donnit le nom de
famille c'est pas facile je vous avoue
c'est pas facile c'est vrai que c'est
pas évident on hésite beaucoup dans le
12 je vais pas prendre le 1 ni la 3 donc
par soustraction on va dire je vais
prendre la 2 tu es d'accord avec ça ou
pas man tu tu confirmes la de tu penses
que c'est la de qui est bien je confirme
et ben bien joué les vous êtes fort vous
êtes très très fort je vous préviens la
saison elle va être très très
longue on commence sur des bas sol
j'adore bon voilà ça permis en même
temps par par ce ce ce petit jeu très
malin de ma part en 94 pieds avec HUG de
de vous présenter donc Ty Proctor et je
pense queon a fait le tour sur son
historique comme je disais rapidement il
y a de la famille qui qui on jouer au
basket professionnel donc un entourage
pro pour rester un peu plus sérieux et
un jeune joueur qui part pour une
deuxème saison à duuk qui est une des
équipes comme Manu va vous en parler les
plus attendu de l'année donc là pass des
incroyable effectivement Manu on connaît
un peu a joué c'est un sopomort donc
c'est un 2è année he à la fac donc on
l'a vu pendant un an euh ça donne quoi
tprctor sur le terrain en année 1 en
année 1 il a de de je vous fais ça de
mémoire au talent comme on dit c'est
plus au début il sort un pas mal du banc
et après il très vite il prend ses des
minutes de titulairire et il devient le
meneur titulaire enfin le l'arrière
titulaire au côté de de Jeremy rooch du
coup c'est c'est c'est un rôle qu'il
occupe encore aujourd'hui sur sa deuxème
saison le début de saison c'est c'est
encore c'est ces deux là qui qui qui
sont sur la ligne arrière et sur sur la
base arrière c'est un j'ai trouvé enfin
en voyant les chiffres je me suis dit
tiens en fait il touche pas autant le
ballon que ça il a un taux taux d'usage
à moins de 20 % ouais donc c'est c'est
assez sur quand on le voit la vidéo
c'est c'est pas l'impression qu'il donne
il donne vraiment l'impression de
d'avoir la balle en fait il tourne
vraiment pas mal il y a beaucoup de
mouvement chez chez lui c joueurs là et
en fait il est juste là en deuxième
initiateur et il fait tourner la la
balle et il prend des des tirs de de
loin quand quand quand il faut c'est
c'est vraiment là son son rôle en
attaque sur sur ces saisons à à dou et
et défensivement c'est c'est plus c'est
de la défense sur les arrières pour
principalement avec un peu délier selon
les les schémas tactiques des
adversaires mais c'est c'est vraiment ça
de l'arrière soit sur le ballon sur le
le point of attaque soit du du Off ball
là je j'ai regardé le match contre
kensas d'hier soir c'est il est beaucoup
sur du Off ball euh ou sur le le
l'arrière le l'ailier et et du coup très
très loin du ballon c'est pas souvent et
pas forcément sur le meilleur joueur non
plus ce qui est assez intéressant
là-dessus on peut se penser qu'avec ces
qualités qu'il a il a des vrais outils
défensifs et Ben qui qui puisse aller
sur le le meilleur joueur adverse en
fait pas pas forcément donc un joueur si
si je résume un petit peu tu as pensé
Manu euh avec des vraies qualités
défensives plutôt dans un rôle de
connecteur en attaque pas forcément
porteur de balle numéro 1 c'est ça on
est un peu dans le vrai sur sa saison 1
ouais c'est ça alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est c'est
quelqu'un dont on entend parler depuis
assez longtemps aussi en jeune qui avait
était plutôt connu je crois si je dis
pas de bêtises he vous me corrigez
messieurs mais pour ces qualité de
scoring et là quand on regarde les
statistiques c'est assez a j'ai envie de
dire dans tout ce qui est pourcentage et
cetera après en not que c'est un bon
tireur de lancer franc il en tire pas
beaucoup mais il est à droit il a 87 %
sur son année 1 je crois qu'est-ce qui
fait que ce jouurl avait déjà des alors
il a finalement décidé de pas se
présenter l'année dernière mais il était
quand même souvent annoncé hein dans les
dans les MOC et cetera et comment si on
s on s'attardte juste au chiffres
comment on explique ça en fait bah je
pense que cette année il avait quand
même Mme plus de responsabilité annoncé
par John cher avec une classe de
recrutement qui était talentueuse mais
les mecs qui arrivent les freshman ont
pe-arlera plus tard dans l'année savait
que si tis Protor restait euh ils
auraient moins de responsabilité donc on
lui a garanti un plus gros rôle euh et
puis un développement de relation avec
un autre joueur dont on va parler dans
nos podcast kel philippovski et donc
voilà plus de plus de répétition montrer
plus de choses et il y a quand même on
va en parler dans son jeu des points de
lacune notamment sur la création de
pullup sur le sur le drible qui font que
c'était pas forcément suffisant pour les
franchises NV pour peut-être mettre un
premier tour de draft l'an dernier parce
que là vu ce qu'on a décrit un beau
lendler qui connecte un général qui
défend pas trop mal qui défend même très
bien c'est pas non plus hyper sexy quand
tu vises une lotque on attend plus que
ça souvent B justement HUG vu que on
parle de un peu son son ticket d'entrée
en NBA qu'est-ce qui va le rendre
valuable ou pas en juin prochain qu sont
un peu
ces les choses qui vont dire au scoot
ouais on peut parer sur ce gars là en
fait il y a deux points pour moi
majoritairement les deux vont être liés
à sa taille donc il fait 1,96 on le
rappelle pour 80 kg il a il a pris en
taille depuis qu'il est arrivé à Duke et
il a pris déjà un peu en masse
musculaire ce qui est
intéressant c'est la défense mais
j'adore le défenseur Ty spctor Manu il
nous dit que effectivement sur les
lignes arrières c'est pas lui qui se
prend toujours le meilleur gar des fois
c'est Jeremy rock mais quand même très
souvent th spctor est chargé de défendre
sur le pick and roll c'est une capacité
à éteindre les driv il a pas c'est pas
forcément hyper flashy ça va pas sur des
stats de steels même s'il en prend plus
d'une par match il est 144 ou de contre
mais c'est une capacité orienté un jouur
dans une direction et lui dire tu ne
passeras pas il donne des lignes et il
attender jusqu'au jusqu'au cercle comm
comme ça et tu vas pas pouvoir marquer
ton panier c'est un joueur qui est hyper
intelligent dans le scooting report pour
savoir quel joueur tire à quel distance
et sur quelle main forte ou pas et en
fonction de ça il va te laisser plus ou
moins d'espace il va passer sous l'écran
ou non donc vraiment un un IQ défensif
sur l'homme est loin du ballon très très
avancé et puis ça on peut le projeter en
en NBA assez rapidement dans une
rotation collective surtout dans une air
où les ballons sont maintenant portés
beaucoup par des des des arrières
offensifs ou des ailiers très offensifs
donc fa compler un petit peu là-dessus
et puis le deuxième point côté général
qu'on sait faire à Duke avec les les
frères Jones un peu plus un peu plus
récemment qui sont allés en en NBS et
une capacité à faire beaucoup de passes
décisives et pas perdre de ballon il a
un ratio ass turnover à plus de trois ce
qui est exceptionnel he pour pour le
niveau NBA c'est pas encore une fois
quelque chose de très flashy mais tout
simplement des très bonnes passes dans
des bons intervalles capables de passer
à une main sur les deux mains capable de
faire de la manipulation visuelle
capable de remonter vite le ballon en
transition il joue avec un excellent
excusez-moi un excellent intérieur en la
personne de Ky philiipovski cette année
et l'an dernier déjà il en a fait un le
meilleur scoreur peut-être de laassc en
freesman et il le continue en somore
donc voilà vraiment un joueur qui va
permettre de remonter le ballon
organiser le jeu ne pas faire d'erreur
et permettre après au peut-être plus
grosses star balle en main offensive
d'avoir des tirs faciles et ça ça
s'achète fort nB quand tu vois les
frères Jones quand tu vois des tyis
Alberton qui a un niveau encore
au-dessus ou d'autres mecs comme ça
gestionnair entre guillemets Manu tu tu
es dans la même veine ouais c'est ce
ticket pour moi c'est galement ça c'est
ce c'est ce côté tout qu'il a et plus ou
moins Plug and Play il va déjà être prêt
quasiment à à jouer dans une deuxième
unité dès dès la saison prochaine siil y
va c'est vraiment ça qui qui est
intéressant cette faculté qu'il a à
défendre sur les ses postes AR NCS c'est
c'est vraiment vraiment impressionnant
il cadre bien il est large sur les
appuis quand quand il défend il est bas
il va assez assez vite même si c'est pas
non plus le le top niveau mais voilz en
NCA il fait il sort du l'au tout de
suite par par ces qualités là et le et
j'aime beaucoup sa sa qualité de
naturelle de de passeur il fait rien de
flashy mais c'est c'est c'est bien ce
qu'il fait en fait là sur la sur la sur
sur ce début de saison il a trois on a
trois matchs joués et il a plus de six
passes décisives de moyenne et c'est ces
passes là on les voit pas en fait c'est
c'est vraiment naturel ce qu'il fait
notamment contre Michigan State hier
soir c'est si passes alors que sur le le
terrain il est très il est très peu en
vue finalement et en fait il apporte
quand même même si voilà il est pas
flashy comme un autre joueur puis peut
l'être à du notamment un CUB Foster qui
a fait une deuxème mi-temps où voilà il
a enchaîné les paniers les paniers les
paniers Proctor c'est un peu l'inverse
il brille dans ce qu'on voit pas
forcément donc la défense et ses petites
passe comme ça de facilitateur de
connecteurs qui moi j'apprécie ce côté
touet donc à avoir je suis pas certain
qui qui soit tant prêt que ça aller à
passer le niveau supérieur parce que
j'ai un autre exemple j'en parlerai j'en
parlerai plus tard à la fin mais je j'ai
encore quelques doutes sur sa capacité à
à vraiment trans ce qui ce qui sait
faire au au au niveau supérieur après je
sais pas si on l'a précisé c'est un
garçon qui est né en 2004 c'est ça donc
il aura 20 ans au moment de la draft
quoi
ouais ce qui est pas ce que le ce qui ce
qui est globalement l'année de naissance
de de beaucoup de joueurs là c cette
année c'est un peu compliqué quand on
suit les Européens aussi du coup on se
dit les Européens sont tous des 2005
cette année ouais et alors que là les
Américains sont beaucoup beaucoup 2004
voir de 2003 3 donc c'est assez
perturbant des fois
je pense je pense qu'il y en a des
millions des 2004 aux États-Unis cette
année ouais c'est ça mais du coup tu dis
en fait il y a toujours plus ou moins un
an de retard enfin de différence avec
les avec un européen c'est c'est assez
étonnant des des fois comment ça se
passe et c'est perturbant parce que du
coup tu ASAS finalement tu as une année
de de décalage et les et l'année de
décalage elle est immense parce que en
Europe il qutiment tous professionnels
ou dans un cadre professionnel du coup
en fait l'évolution elle est beaucoup
plus rapide chez chez ces Américains des
freshman de 23 de 2003 donc en fait ils
avaient 19 ans ils jouent encore au
lycée donc en fait leur domination elle
est elle est logique que ce soit par le
physique ils ont déjà quasiment entre 3
et et un an d'avance sur leur opposition
donc c'est c'est vraiment quelque chose
de de perturbant qu' on arrive parce que
c'est pas toujours le temp à arrive à
trouver les dates de naissance on va
parler justement de Don là on a vraiment
parlé de ces skills vendeurs on va dire
qu qui doit justement il est revenu à la
fac qu'est-ce qu' doit chercher
absolument à développer pour vraiment
s'installer comme un first pick en pas
un first pick un First
Round sûr pour cette année moi je pense
qu'il doit vraiment améliorer son tir
c'est c'est vraiment le là aujourd'hui
le le le son point faible je je
m'attendit pas des chiffres aussi bas en
fait don dans le jeu il paraît vraiment
beaucoup fort que ça beaucoup plus en h
que ça alors que finalement sur le le 3
points l'année dernière il a il est il a
32 % ce qui est pour un arrière c'est
pas dans un arrière dont la NBA
d'aujourd'hui est assez faible et cette
année il a 27 % sur trois matchs donc
l'échantillon est beaucoup trop faible
pour pour faire une comparaison mais
c'est pour moi c'est c'est vraiment ça
le le point qui doit améliorer parce
qu'on on voit de la diversité du Off
screen du pullup du du du catch in shoot
il est beaucoup dans catch shoot
d'ailleurs mais du coup on on sent qu'il
peut le faire et le pourcentage au
lancer Fran est assez intéressant laisse
espérer aussi qu'il a encore de la que
le travail s'il travaille avec le le
staff NBA il va trouver tout de suite
les choses à améliorer et euh ça va la
la progression va être assez être assez
linéaire et simple en fait c'est des
choses qu'on va pouvoir voir dès la dès
la Summer League en fait tellement ça va
vite avec un un staff NBA ouais surtout
que en plus la mécanique a pas l'air
d'être l'air vraiment d'être plutôt
correcte c'est ça tout est assez fluide
donc c'est vraiment des petits détails
d'appui de pied de position de doigt de
voilà des choses comme ça qui qu' va
falloir juste modifier qui prennent le
rythme de ça mais à force de tir c'est
c'est des choses que làdessus je suis
pas forcément inquiet HUG on t'écoute
ouais je vais rond sur le tir parce que
je suis assez d'accord là-dessus le C
j'ai pas trop d'inquiétude là je
regardais un peu dans les dans le détail
effec on a TR é tro matchs en
échantillon mais c'est 75 % de catch and
shoot 25 % donc falloir mettre ça en en
place et puis de façon globale un mec l'
tripic on va attendre qu'il puisse quand
même initier un peu du pick and roll
normalement je sais que c'est une classe
de draft on va en parler tout de la
saison qui est assez faible en terme de
talent notamment en terme de création
benling va falloir quand même pouvoir
initier du pit and roll et si vous
regardez le match contre Michigan State
hier d' match l'an
dernier passe tout sous l'écran et du
coup il part en drive avec un défenseur
qui a déjà deux pieds dans la raquette
et il arrive à rien et ça c'est vraiment
très problématique sa capacité à créer
du pullup sur pick and roll qui a pour
l'instant est inexistante et donc très
vite les défenses NBI vont faire la
passe elles vont passer dessous dessous
dessous et tu vas être dans comme
beaucoup
d'arrière en NBA on va te la retirer des
balles la main tu vas être vraiment sur
un poste de Sendy extérieur et c'est pas
suffisant je pense pour être un l'ut
tripque et ça va en lien aussi avec la
capacité à poser le ballon le drible
Manu l'a dit c'est pas un énorme athlète
c'est un joueur très correct hein mais
c'est pas une énorme explosivité et
c'est une une capacité à changer de
direction changer de vitesse changer de
rythme qui est pour le moment pas
suffisante je pense euh pour le niveau
NBA ce qu'on aime bien c'est lorsqu'on
est sur une défense de drop sur pitch
and roll euh lorsque le poseur d'écran a
vraiment mis un bon contact et que du
coup le le pivot adverse est campé sous
le cercle capacité à bien lire le jeu
flotteur midrange passe ça il l'a en
main donc ça va lui donner de l'espace
mais voilà sur des fins de match et au
fur et à mesure que la saison NBA va
avancer être capable de pouvoir
sanctionner sur du sur du pullup sur de
la prise de décision ou bien refuser des
écrans pour s'accéder au cercle mais
trouver des moyens pour exister balle en
main histoire d'être un Top 14 et ça
personnellement j'y crois pas
particulièrement sur le long terme après
de mémoire je crois qu' au niveau au
niveau des des longs deux euh comme
c'est décrit dans les States avancé il
est plutôt correct euh au Cercle ça
donne quoi parce que là j'ai
l'impression que tu me dépins un joueur
vraiment horrible au niveau de la
finition au cercle il est à
ouais il est à 50 % au panier donc
vraiment sous le panier euh c'est 14 %
de ses tirs ça c'est vraiment beaucoup
trop faible donc il va il y va très très
peu alors après c'est un jeu NCA où tu
as un mec comme kilipovski même s'il
peut écarter le jeu un mec comme
philippowski qui est quand même très
présent poste bas Marc Mitchel est pas
un énorme sniper donc Marc Mitchel vient
souvent dans le cut donc boucher encore
poste bas euh joyung quand il est sur le
terrain le le 5e année là poste 45 fait
que du poste bas aussi donc voilà on
aura un spacing NBA plus aéré euh avant
que Manu a une comparaison tu vois je
parlais tout à l'heure de tax liberton
c'est le scénario ultra optimal inespéré
pour moi même il y a un autre joueur qui
me vient en tête c'est den Terry den
Terry qui est en 2e année dans en NBA
chez les Chicago Bull même si pour
l'instant il fait que des gifs sur
Twitter il sert à ça maisry il fait deux
saisons à Arizona donc deux saisons
universitaire il fait à peu près la même
taille il est il a 3 cm de plus il fait
le même poids euh on a les mêmes stats
en terme de passe décisive on a les
mêmes stat en terme de défensive on a un
problème de tir avec un volume plus bas
un problème de créer des dans S franc et
on le voit aujourd'hui en NBA et même en
NG League le drible est vraiment pas
suffisant et donc ce mec-l se retrouve à
faire du suendy mais comme il tire pas
assez bien il joue pas et donc c'est un
scénario faut faire attention AOR je dis
pas que c'est ça va être un buz
forcément qui jouera pas mais tu as un
mec qui est pris top 20 et on est déjà à
se poser des questions sur la fin de
carrière de Don Terry euh et ça c'est un
truc qu'on va pouvoir regarder je pense
que si les franchises l'an dernier lui
ont dit attends un petit peu c'est
peut-être pour éviter de faire ce
scénario là qui peut être la pire chose
qui puisse lui arrivé arriver dans une
équipe où il joue pas et il se développe
pas et comme le drible est pas suffisant
et que le CAT shoot est pas suffisant
ben en fait on va prendre quelqu'un
d'autre de plus spécialiste que toi même
s'il a moins de talent et même s'il
défend un peu moins bien euh al c'est
intéressant parce que tu nous a parlé du
du scénario possible une fois qu'il sera
drafté Manu tu te positionnes comment
alors même si comparaison n'est pas
raison si tu as un joueur qui vient en
tête hésite pas ouais moi ma comparaison
c'était bon c'est un peu le même style
que que d' c'était plus d and Daniels
qui qui lui a fait sa qui a fait sa sa
sa formation on va dire en en J League
et et c'est pareil c'est un un joueur
qui a les mêmes qualités les mêmes
défauts c'est sa défense et son tir
c'est et en jag on l'a très rapidement
vu et au pelicans B il a il arrive pas
non plus à percer parce que justement il
a pas il a pas réussi à transférer
toutes ces qualités là notamment en
attaque ou finalement en attaque c'est
ce qu'on voyait un peu en J c'est que le
le drible n'est pas suffisant la
création pour les autres n'est pas
forcément suffisante non plus alors
qu'il en a les capacités et finalement
on se retrouve avec un joueur de de banc
de de 2è unité voir trème unité qui qui
a aucun impact que ce soit en attaque ou
en défense alors que ça aurait dû être
un un joueur capable de d'entrer dans la
rotation derrière un un S mcum
à l'époque et aujourd'hui on voit bien
même quand là si jelum n'est pas là bah
on voit un autre ooki là cette année
hakins
qui la place parce c'est c'est un vrai
spécialiste du tir quoi moi je regarde
quelques matchs parce que je vois ses
chiffres et le gars il fait ce qu'il
sait faire et et justement ça ça l'aide
même si c'est que un spécialiste du tir
bah il score il score il score il a des
chiffres incroyables cette saison 37 % à
3 points ou quelque chose comme ça ce
qui est juste fou et il en prend pas
trois par match il en prend 12 donc ça
c'est assez fou et et mais tuis daenel
n'a pas réussi justement à prendre ce
rôle- làà qui est laissé un rooki et moi
j'ai chez Proctor j'ai j'ai peur de ça
qu'il arrive pas forcément à à
capitaliser sur ses sur ses points forts
et que les points faibles ne soient pas
forcément assez travaillé et que ça
devienne un point négatif pour lui du
fait de
de et pas réussir à gagner ces minutes
là finalement et rester sur le banc et
ne pas avoir deuxième contrat NBA et
partir peut-être en Europe ou ou ou
autre part et finir par manger des
agendas et et sombrer dans la dépression
faire 65 kg e on est on commence de
bonne humeur les gars franchement on est
on est on est chaud Patat cette année ça
va bien se passer hein ça va bien se
passer j'avais un meilleur scénario
possible à vous proposer vous me dites
par rapport à la description du joueur
moi il y a le meilleur scénario possible
je pensais à une sorte de derck White
like derck white quand il est arrivé
plutôt côté sint Antonio est-ce que on
peut être un peu dans ça ouais il va
falloir falloir enchaîner les shoots va
falloir quand même bien travailler ça et
puis dCK White a a une science du du cut
la lecture de jeu et de la finition
quand même près du cercle c'est c'est un
très bel athlète quoi derck white donc
je lui souhaite je suis pas non plus on
va pas non plus enterrer le le joueur
parce que quand il a e vraiment il faut
que j'arrête avec ce stylo quand il a
des des espaces il joue très très bien
il va vraiment falloir se donner les
moyens de d'utiliser ses limites pour
pouvoir arriver quand même à se faire
des espaces est-ce que alors moi je suis
peut-être un petit peu optimiste pour le
coup mais c'est un joueur qui avant la
NC tuit connu pour être un gros scoreur
qui a quand même qui scorit pas mal
est-ce que ça c'est pas ça peut pas être
un peu rassurant justement pour les SCO
de voir un peu du film de ce qu'il a pu
donner en jeune avec avec l'Australie ça
ça peut après c'est on lui demande on va
pas forcément lui demander de faire ça
de scorer en NB est-ce que ça correspond
à ce qu'il recherche je suis pas certain
après je sais plus qui que ces défauts
deviennent pas des pas des gros points
noirs en fait faut qu'il arrive quand
même à être dangereux et que les
défenses a peur de lui qu'il soit qu'il
ait peur qu'il tire ou qu'il a au cercle
ou du pouup mistance voilà faut vraiment
qu'il arrive à être dangereux sur ces
trois niveaux là s'il arrive à
capitaliser là-dessus et en étant bon en
défense derrière pas forcément un là je
vois pas forcément de point noir faut
juste que encore une fois on en
reviendra je vais en revenir là-dessus
toute l'année c'est le contexte ouais si
s'il tombe dans un très très bon
contexte dans une équipe qui qui veut de
lui qui qui va avoir très peu de
concurrence ouou ce genre de chos il
peut il peut très très vite monter en
gamme ou sil tombe dans une équipe type
Lakers où on va le voir qu'avec uchifino
cette année où il joue absolument pas
envie de crever il il peut très bien
rester 4 ans jé quoi on il y a un point
qu'on a pas abordé c'est le côté un
petit peu psychologique l'être humain
qui est terise Proctor euh ça donne quoi
sur un terrain terise Proctor c'est
quelqu'un qui est capable de c'est un
côté un peu leader un peu aboyeur
quelqu'un de discret de qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'il émane de lui sur un
terrain de basket en tout cas qu'est-ce
que les est-ce que il y a des Red Flag
qui auraient pu être vu par par les SP
par rapport à son comportement par
rapport à d'autres coéquipiers une
capacité à s'agacer je sais pas Manu non
c'est un enfin à l'écran en tout cas moi
j'ai pas aperçu ça c'est un gars qui est
très dans qui est très positif qui voilà
quand il y a le quand il y a Lele là
quasiment à chaque coup de sifflet c'est
lui qui fait venir les joueurs c'est lui
qui parle c'est vraiment le c'est
quasiment le capitaine de l'équipe même
si officiellement ça l'est pas c'est
voilà c'est c'est quelqu'un qui est
présent vraiment tout le temps qui qui
parle beaucoup je trouve et et sur le
banc aussi il est très positif on le
voit sur certains highl où voilà il
hésite pas à se lever à prendre à
applaudir à encourager ses ses
coéquipiers donc à l'écran en tout cas
moi j'ai pas vu de de
choses négativ on va finir sur deux
choses euh le comment vous le l'imaginez
pour sa première année en NBA qu'est-ce
qu'on va lui demander de faire et déjà
est-ce qu'il va pouvoir voir le terrain
parce que là avec tous les exemples que
vous m'avez donné j'ai l'impression que
si on voit un jour sur un park NBA en
2025 ce sera beau bah honnêtement on
pense pas qu'il va jouer beaucoup la
première année sauf quatre blessures fa
effectivement un contexte contexte
optimal il va faire des allretours avec
les G peut-être sortir un peu du banc on
va lui demander quand tu rentre de faire
briller un intérieur on va lui demander
de défendre sur peut-être le meilleur
extérieur adverse de sa première année
et met tes tirs à TR points dans le
corner si tu peux me donner de tirs en
catch and shoot une bonne transition de
bonnes transitions tu remontes le ballon
après r parce qu'il même assez grand
même s'il prend pas énormément de rebond
dans cette équipe de duuk qui galère au
global au rebond mais de remonter la
balle très rapidement et de lancer ta
star jeune Oden que je ne sais pas où tu
pourrais tomber tu vois ben ça peut être
ça peut déjà ça très bien et puis
derrière angelque faire des répétitions
des gammes des games des gammes B en
main et épaissie ton jeu épaissie ton
corps et et donne-toi des gammes ouais
Manu
moi je le vois sortir du sortir du banc
être vraiment dans les sur ses premers
premières années enfin la première année
en tout cas être sortir du banc voir
être un joueur au tout début de garb
time et qui fera ses Games en en jleague
et je pense que la jue peut vraiment
l'aider il y a quand même pas mal de
j'ai l'impression que les équipes NBL
prennent beaucoup plus au sérieux ce
cette possibilité là il y a vraiment
beaucoup de joueurs qui qui font leur
gamme là-bas et qui reviennent très très
bon donc je je pense que ça peut être
une belle option pour lui de d'avoir une
année angéque pour que voilà il il
prennent ses gammes il arrive à à
comprendre le jou NBA le prendre
conscience du terrain des règles du
spacing de de plusieurs choses et de
faire des voyages en avec l'équipe NBA
et prendre des minutes comme ça comme
hugladi moi je l'attends surtout sur sa
défense je pense que c'est vraiment ça
qui va lui donner des points et en
attaque faut que l'attaque pour moi ce
sera que du bonus si effectivement il
shoot à il shoot et il marque quand il
est ouvert déjà pour que les les équipe
a conscience que bah c'est une un un
point dangereux il va falloir le le
défendre et le prendre au sérieux et du
coup s'il arrive à faire ça et qu'il met
dedans franchement c'est tout BF et
après il pourra driver et voir s'il
améliore justement ce handle ce premier
pas cette prise de vitesse cette
accélération dans le drible que pour
l'instant il a pas encore juste parce
qu'on l'a pas précisé vous l'imaginez
capable parce que sa défense et sur
l'homme c'est une de ses qualités vous
l'imaginez capable de défendre combien
de postes en NBA c'est comme ça c'est
super important parce que c'est aussi ce
qui peut faire rentrer dans un dans les
rotations moi deux deux ouais ouais de 3
peut-être les des ailiers fallir
épaissir le coffre et il est pas
inintéressant sur les sur les lectures
face au Big c'est pas va pas switcher
sur un grand mais il sait contestin un
tripass tu vois sur poste bas il sait
faire une rotation il sait trapper sur
pit and roll et tout ça donc normalement
il sera toujours positif je le vois pas
trop je vois pas trop comment tu peux
cibler tais Proctor en défense ok un
avir rapide pour finir on y croit on y
croit moyen on y croit pas du tout
messieur la sentence va être terrible je
vous
écoute moi personnellement c'est moyen
moyen ouais ouais pareil je me le
draftais pas trop haut j'aime bien le
joueur faut faut faut passer la marche
quoi OK et ben si va se finir le premier
épisode de Five Star n'hésitez pas à
commenter liker à nous faire des retours
surtout c'est important on va essayer
aussi de s'ajuster au fur à mesure de la
saison un petit peu comme nos prospects
et de faire monter nos stocks et nos
intangibles sur ce je vous souhaite à
tous une excellente journée ou soirée
selon de quand vous nous écoutez et je
vous dis à très vite bye
[Musique]
bye